The Joe Rogan Experience that right here
right handle perfect too the timing of
that yeah and the knee on the [ __ ]
cheekbone yeah it was a good fight it
was a beautiful fight and how satisfying
was that for you to come back from the
first fight that you guys had it was
good
um it was good but
that guy's facing the right I think it's
a Matchmaker Rick is hilarious
um for me
after the after the first fight I had
with him I went through like I think
2019 I think it was 2019 2000 2020 was a
huge like shift
in my life you know that affected me
differently and my mindset and so when I
lost that first fight to him I was so
wasn't mad about losing I was mad about
I put so much pressure on myself
about being perfect
and it just drove me insane like
everything I want to do is perfect I
still had that in me but
in what way what do you mean so I don't
know like I felt like I remember being a
hotel room and I rewatched the fight and
then I felt like it was just at their
cup so my my sister passed during uh I
was getting ready for a fight right
that's what kind of stem from so I was
getting ready for a fight my sister she
she died and then seeing her pass and
then seeing basically the End Game of
Life right like being here and seeing
her just like she's there and then
seeing her go through the trauma and
then her being gone and then seeing the
traumatic how it affected my mom and
after you know I remember when
everything happened I was in the
hospital I was like
you guys need help clean up all this
Blood because I can I can I can help and
she goes honey that's okay just just go
home I was like
all right Mom I love you let me know if
you need me I'll go home started balling
my wife's there I mean that was a huge
uh movement in my life where I was like
that's a [ __ ] in game like doesn't
matter what you've done before that's
you can either go peaceful you go you
know traumatic right
so that happened
and that was and then it was pointing me
I was like damn like I called Matt and I
was like hey I'm not gonna be I was like
hey I'm not gonna be in training today I
gotta go bury my sister right and I took
a step back and I was like [ __ ] man I'm
always training for a fight always
waiting for a fight and my sister just
died and I'm I can't go train because I
gotta go bury here but there was like
weird [ __ ] to my mind I was like I'm
always getting ready for a fight always
getting me for a fight and then I went
and fought won the World Grand Prix fast
forward get ready to fight Adriana if we
go through covid-19 right all the gyms
are shut down our gym kind of like we
got uh relocated so there's only three
of us training
and then I fight Adriano and I was the
game plan was there but I just felt like
I wasn't
if I came back from The Knockout he was
like you know when you left I wasn't
comfortable where you're at like when
you left I was like you're just gonna
have to fight through this you're gonna
have to get through it and then sit in a
hotel room and I was like why am I why
am I putting distress on myself why for
what and then
that was like kind of like a snapping
period Then when I fought Rob Tang I was
like
everybody's so worried about winning and
losing why
why because you're gonna die someday
you're gonna die someday right so why
the [ __ ] do you worry about winning lose
are you having fun yeah okay perfect who
cares you want to lose so I went there
to fight him I was like all right you
know I said I told man I was like I'm
not gonna [ __ ] run like I'm gonna
exchange like I don't care if he has a
hard chain I'm gonna go out there and
give him my best and then there's a ASAP
Rocky said when has it ever been cool to
knock somebody down it's never been uh
cool whoever made it cool to belittle
somebody or whatever is not cool right
so that's always in the back of my head
so when I thought rotting and then I I
felt that success not success but I felt
like I won the fight and I was like oh
no you did good job I was like thanks
man appreciate it you know go back home
take care of the wife and kids and then
went off by Adriana the second time I
was like we do the training camp it was
probably the toughest training camp but
I started doing things different right
like before I'm like I gotta be perfect
I can't I can't have any beer I can't go
watch concert I gotta be strict and I
was like I think the last sparring
session after the Adrian fight I was
like went to a concert had two beer
years had a [ __ ] chicken sandwich and
I'm like I need to enjoy my life because
eventually I'm going to die right and I
don't want to be at my deathbed I was
like man I was so strict and all that
stuff like I want to enjoy my life and
so that right there from that
traumatic thing in my life it's just
shifted my my whole perspective like on
my birthday August 13th I was my wife
was like oh we didn't get you any
alcohol we just got you know all water
and I was like no give me a [ __ ]
glass of champagne like I'm 30 I'm 36
years old like I I've been doing this
for [ __ ] if I if I train eight weeks
and I can have one [ __ ] beer and it's
Gonna Change My outcome of winning this
fight then I don't deserve to win the
fight I guess so it is what it is so I
feel like that and that whole mindset is
just made me a better a better athlete
better fighter because it's released
some pressure from you from pressure of
being perfect right and that's how it is
like I remember one day I was like I
just grappled that new wave right and I
was grabbing a kid who was 18 years old
and he was [ __ ] working me and
someone who has an ego who'd be like I'm
the best fighter in the world like that
should never happen for me I'm like dude
you're [ __ ] good good job I'm so
excited to see I'm so excited to see
what you've been able to achieve in the
nine years you've been grappling under
John Dunner hand like I'm so happy for
you so proud of you you I want to follow
you I want to follow your career right
like just my whole mindset has just
shipped and
yeah I don't know what it is I mean I
know what it is it's that but for me
that's how I like to look at my fights
now and yeah it's been making me Randy
code torso that wants to me yeah he was
talking about uh fighting and winning
he's like so many people put so much
pressure on winning he's like he goes
you do your best he goes you're trying
to win and if you lose the same people
who love you they're still going to love
you you're still going to have your
friends you're gonna be okay yeah and
that's
that's that's like taking my game to the
Holland level like I truly believe that
like but I believe that believe that
like just that mindset is like I don't
give a [ __ ] what happens like like
they're like who are you gonna fight yes
I'm like I don't care it doesn't change
does it change my pay does it change my
outlook on life it doesn't doesn't
change me from my end game which is
Financial Freedom right so it doesn't
care I don't care who it is you know
what it is I just want to make sure that
I never lose focus of my end game and
yeah that's helped me a lot